what's up everyone welcome back for
another san diego comic con 2022
interview i have the cast of the new
interview with the vampire series hello
congratulations even though i have seen
nothing i'm just so hyped that i have
all the faith in the world in all of you
well look at them of course it's great
it is great i believe it instantly
all right so first thing i want to ask
you here is for each of you to chime in
on this what do you think it is about
adapting this material to the series
format that i don't know maybe gives you
more room to play or an added layer than
maybe they had had in the previous film
adaptation i think something that's so
brilliant about amritsar's books is that
she really gives space to get to know
all of these characters and she's and
these like huge passages that just delve
into backstory and into who they are as
people so that then you have these
little moments of plot that means so
much because of everything you've
learned and i think
that in this format you get to do that
like you get to really get into the
weeds of who these hoodies
keep wanting to say people are but
they're not people who these characters
are these vampires are yeah we have
seven hours to explore this really dense
beautiful world and we get to bring in
more elements from different books and
we get to expand that sort of universe
and i think i think people who are a fan
of the whole vampire chronicles would be
can be very excited actually because we
get to bring in more things than the
film ever got a chance to do which you
know i love the film though yeah we have
a lot of easter eggs you're on the edge
of your seat on each episode because we
really get to dive deeper into the
characters it's my kind of adaptation i
like it i was also going to say vampires
are people too but maybe it's vampires
were people too
yeah
that's a better way to put it all right
some have more humanity than it is all
right jacob for you specifically now you
obviously know a thing or two about
adapting very popular source material to
screen yeah what is something about your
process that stayed the same from game
of thrones to here in terms of bringing
your character to life but then also
what is something about interview with
the vampire that posed a unique
challenge and how to you know have you
change up your approach to the work well
i don't know if i brought a lot although
i think that i think louis is a very
thoughtful character he's very watchful
i think grey worm has also kind of had
that quality to him but louis talks a
lot more
he wants to really like get into it i
think there's like a unique challenge
with this show is that
these characters have lived for decades
or for it for a decade and
to kind of track that journey and
who somebody is when they're
147 versus who somebody is when they're
in their 30s is is really hard and it's
like trying to figure out at which point
did he change what did he pick up from
this what did he pick up from there what
did he bring
louie brings everything with him he's
just
he's got so much baggage
he's like i don't think he leaves
anything behind in his human existence
but yeah that's part of the reason why
vampire stories always fascinate me yeah
like we can't experience that whatsoever
um bailly for you
you're having quite the couple of years
right now
you came to this series after having
worked with james cameron on avatar and
him in particular he is one of the most
iconic directors out there who also has
a habit of revolutionizing the industry
and doing very unique things on his film
so is there anything you saw him do like
a one-of-a-kind tactic in terms of
bringing material to life and directing
actors that left you with a new tool in
your back pocket that you were able to
apply to your work on this show well the
great thing about both of these projects
is like there's so much detail
and it with this being so much like i've
never done live action before because i
play a blue person in avatar so being on
a live action set where like there's a
full town house and couches that i can
sit on was really interesting but then
learning the skill of imagination and
avatar i was really able to apply when
playing claudia because i am playing
this extreme character who's 14. it was
stuck in this 14 year old body but then
has to explore these older ages what a
fascinating transition
another another question for that what
is something about doing live action
acting for the camera that you know
called for some sort of readjustment
where the way the charac the camera
picks up your performance in that case
is different than something like avatar
fortunately i was able to have the whole
world mara built this big set and every
detail is there you look around the
entire room 360 and it's the entire
apartment so i was able to play with
that the same way on a sound stage yes
it's gray
but i get to imagine the world it's just
more internal compared to on a live
action set it's external sam i'm coming
your way now for this particular role i
was reading that they got quite a few
audition tapes for it but yours
immediately stood out so it was making
me wonder what were some of your goals
for that particular audition but then
how did those goals for the character
change once you booked the role and
started working on the show well i've
been a huge fan of these books for a
very long time so when i heard that they
were going to make the show like i
really wanted the opportunity to
audition so i was really excited um that
i had the opportunity to give it a go so
i went back to the books looked at the
character and then that sort of once i
was cast is the same thing that i just
kept going back to the books going back
to anne rice and you know i feel an
immense amount of pressure taking this
character on because he's someone who i
really love
um so i want to do the best that you
know i can do and you know honor him and
honor the work that that anne did yeah
so
it's it's it's very exciting but super
exciting again i got faith i can't wait
to see it all right eric you're up so
for you your character in the book was a
young boy when he conducted the
interview now he is a seasoned
journalist what is something about his
approach to interviewing that is gained
from his experience as a journalist but
then also what is something about the
original rendition of the character that
you wanted to you know hold true to and
have even though he is more experienced
in this show well the boy in the book
is ambitious i mean the whole thing that
motivates him to make the recordings in
the first place is he's got a little bit
more than the average bear when it comes
to let's go get that story and that gets
him in
in the muck of this whole thing to begin
with
but now it's 40 something years later he
has a lot of experience as a actually
very accomplished journalist he's one
pulitzer's he's
he's he's badass when it comes to go
getting the story and here's this story
that falls on him the vampire wants to
talk again
and he thinks this could be his ticket
to the to the big prize
but it's super dangerous i mean
he could get killed the vampire might
eat him so what then i mean he
he's uh
he's willing to go get he he's got a lot
at stake and he's ready to go for it and
uh but it's it's with all that
experience he's the old dog who knows
what he's going after now i understand
that mentality if you were an
uh vampire would happily interview you
and take that risk
why not
so one of my absolute favorite things
about source material that is adapted
multiple times is that everyone has a
different interpretation of the material
and you usually do wind up being able to
highlight something new that we haven't
seen before in that material so for each
of you what is something specifically
about your character that is unique to
you that you know maybe brought
something out in the source material
that we haven't really highlighted
before whether it's the source material
itself or the movie
for me for me i think it's and i i love
how much louie aches in the book i love
that he
he is mourning his past existence and
and our louie very much is is very much
that as well but um
but i'd say our louie has like a little
bit more uh
punch to him i think he's more inclined
to
to to go at least that
rather than sort of uh
initially he's slightly less brooding
but we get there
we get there but yeah i'd say he's um
got a little bit more bite in him yeah
i would say
claudia we dive deeper into how much
claudia
wants love not just from louie and lasat
but also from other people from to find
her companion the way louis and lasad
have each other she wants that so we
dive deeper into that
and i'd say for our version of the start
what we get to do is go
into the
subsequent books that the film you know
didn't get the chance to necessarily do
and we take that second edition that
anne sort of went on with and bring him
into um into our story so he's a more
complex
um character and you get to learn a bit
more about you know his backstory uh not
too much because he you know keeps his
cards to himself but you you you
understand him a bit more i think yeah
all right eric how about you well the
the
i mean me and daniel we we're on the
same arc i'm in the same place in my
life that daniel is and i've had my ups
and downs and now i'm a curmudgeon as i
become this older
uh character in my real life and it's
kind of like who he is and for me that's
actually a challenge i've played some
very broad characters in the in my day
and now i'm playing a guy who's actually
kind of driving along the next lane just
over for me and it's it's interesting it
was a real challenge all right before i
have to wind down with you guys we're
going to play a game i'm going to put a
a different type of supernatural spin on
this game so
rather than vampires i'm going to make
the zombies so i'm going to give you a
description of you know like a zombie
movie cliche and i want you to tell me
which real actor best suits this
description and whoever shouts out their
answer first is right so good luck with
that that's the cast yes so
i'm gonna i'm gonna set the scene right
now you're all on set filming an episode
of this show a zombie outbreak happens
so the first one is who is most likely
to be the last to catch on and not
realize the set has been overrun by
zombies me
i say bailey oh
i'm gonna say eric but yeah
i'll be honest why because i'm in la la
land like i'm so happy i look for the
joy i won't even notice that they're
being zombies
that's what i thought yeah yeah that's
kind of a lovely reason i would make
friends with the zombies
all right who is the most likely to
sacrifice themselves for the others
jacob
[Music]
jacob yeah jacob that's like the highest
compliment you can get in this game i
love it all right who is the most likely
to trip and fall while running from the
zombies
i don't have any ability to run from
zombies i get scared and then i always
fall down when zombies are chasing me
but then jacob will sacrifice himself
for you and you'll live happily ever
after
i love this one who is most likely to
get bit and then try to hide their
infection from the group oh we know who
that is is this
there's only one guy left
i think he's probably how long do you
have to hide it though
for eternity you're just an eternity and
you're good at it
i feel like there's two ways to look at
that question you could either hide it
because like you're too scared to admit
it you don't want everybody else to kill
you or you're hiding it to preserve your
own life so you could help and fight for
the other so you could either take that
as a compliment or not i mean i think
you probably like try and hide it and
then like we can all be a zombie gang
together right i mean i would watch that
show for selfish reasons
who is most likely to be the last one
standing sam
yep sam sam kind of for the reasons we
just said
[Laughter]
all right so this doesn't this one
doesn't really happen in zombie movies
but i like thinking about it
who is the most likely to get bit and
get turned into a zombie but have the
willpower to fight the change and then
come back at the last possible second
and save the day can i just can i say
louie
oh that's a yeah
[Music]
to an extent that's like him
i'll let you have
eric's pretty stubborn
louis is the perfect answer to that
question though
all right i gotta let you guys go
congratulations again i am counting down
the seconds until i can see your show
enjoy comic con to everybody out there
keep an eye out for interview with the
vampire the series check it out
you